you
welcome to the hundred sixty-six
commencement exercises of Hillsdale
College thank you for coming this is our
largest crowd they've been getting
bigger and bigger anyway in this year we
tried to suppress the name of the
speaker but we were unsuccessful the
purpose of the college from its first
day is the protection of perpetuation of
civil and religious freedom and
intelligent hiding through sound
learning we are commencing to live a
good life and learning and faith add to
moral character are the essentials of
that good life we call it commenced
because these seniors have qualified
themselves to commence that life
they won't master it ever and not even
nearly completely us they keep at it but
they have surely been at it here 366
strong representing 37 states and 5
countries you persevere through all of
the most challenging education anywhere
in the country we live in an age of grim
relativism
but here this class has seen the power
of unchanging truth to change lives
you've learned the character is destiny
and that it's essential to
self-government and that right condom is
its own reward as you prepare to leave
this special place I just encourage you
to take your convictions into every
facet of your life it will require
courage and tenacity and greatness of
spirit at times you will face opposition
for taking a stand for what you know to
be right but as you've learned here at
Hillsdale strength rejoices in the
challenge
[Music]
[Applause]